the arctic circle is the line above
which you get midnight sun
at least one day a year and also where
you get one day where the sun doesn't
peak above the horizon at all
but despite its reputation for being
cold and northern
iceland is not above the arctic circle
well most of it isn't there is one part
of a tiny island
called grimsey north of acarari which is
where i am now
grimsey is home to fewer than 100 people
and way more than 100 puffins
and it's a good story i was going to
travel there i was going to see the
monument that they built
at the arctic circle line but because
the earth wobbles on its axis the arctic
circle is moving north
so there's now a new monument an 8 ton
spherical stone
boulder that they can move every year as
the line moves
in about 50 years they'll probably have
to move it into the ocean because the
arctic circle will have
left the island of grimsey for a few
millennia
and iceland so my story went will no
longer have any territory
above the arctic circle decent story
right
but then i found that there's another
bit of iceland above the arctic circle
another 60 kilometers or so further
north a small uninhabitable bit of rock
called culvency and that's the sort of
technicality i have to pay attention to
if i
don't want several hundred emails
pointing out that i'm wrong and so
the story about grimsey sort of fell
apart it didn't work anymore
except there's one line on the wikipedia
article about that small
uninhabitable bit of rock it is subject
to rapid
wave erosion and is expected to
disappear in the near future
probably around the year 2020.
the trouble is there's no way for a
tourist to get out to colburn city it's
just
a tiny bit of rock to see if it's still
there you'd have to charter a plane
so i charged a plane
[Music]
we're flying out right now to the
coordinates of where culver c
might be or might not be here's what i
know in the 17th century
calvin c was about 700 by 100 meters
and about 100 meters tall it was a
massive remnant of an old volcanic
eruption but it's been steadily
constantly eroded by the ocean by freeze
thor cycles and
by sea ice in winter by 1986
it was only about 40 meters by 40 meters
and it only reached about five meters
above the weight
iceland built a helipad on there to try
and stop it eroding but by 2006 the
coast guard here
reported that the helicopter had
collapsed iceland isn't reinforcing
coldness anymore they seem to have
abandoned it to the waves and
it might not seem like that matters but
tiny places
like that can make a difference because
countries territorial limits and
exclusive fishing areas
are sometimes decided by rocks like that
in the mid 20th century the uk and
iceland had what the british media
dramatically called the cod wars
disputes about fishing rights
near iceland and by the way iceland won
the uk concealed now carbon c
is mentioned in legal documents about
isis territorial limits
but i'm also not really sure whether it
matters
to work out what's going to happen when
it disappears you'd need an expert in
international maritime law and
frankly a psychic because the answer
likely is
it gets settled by negotiations between
governments not by some rando and a
plane guy
hey your island isn't there anymore but
it does feel a bit provocative for me
as a british person to be checking up on
whether iceland's rock is still there
all right we are approaching the
coordinates
we are flying only 500 feet above the
waves that's about 150 meters
it's low tide the weather is clear if
there was
ever a chance to see if is still there
this is it
[Music]
i think i can see it
i'm pretty sure that's it up ahead
oh man there's barely anything
that used to be an island 700 meters by
100 meters and that's all that's left
and yes it's eroded away but it looks
like the predictions were a little bit
pessimistic
there's two little islands still poking
above the water
importantly it is still there at low
tide it is still above the waves iceland
your island is still there you're
welcome
this video was inspired by some tweets
from sam hughes a brilliant science
fiction author
i recommend his books ra and find
structure he's also responsible for the
anti-mimetics division stories
over on the scp wiki i've linked his
work in the description sam
thank you very much